you never wrote a song for Leslie but
and so now you have write and you're
wanting to serenade her right well
here's the thing our anniversary is
today but we really can't go anywhere or
I can't buy her a present because we're
you know isolated in the house so what I
did is I tried to write a song okay and
someone's gonna hand it to you right now
and I would like you to sing it so
Leslie
sing it yeah this is this is a tribute
to Leslie at our 23 year marriage sung
by you and how good you do this will
determine if she thinks if it was a good
present also the lyrics might determine
a good song I think it's all in the
performance I mean the lyrics are fine
but I feel like you have to like give it
your all I need some vocal gymnastics
okay I need you to really bring your
a-game you know to this or I'm gonna get
in trouble quite honestly fine here we
go let's do it
I've been a really bad at a game I can
leave serenader 23 games for 23 games
y'all have been in my heart but 20 years
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah keep going keep going
with a gymnastic okay okay
for 23 years I've been the luckiest man
on the face of the world usually one
would say planet it's fine
oh it's what and 20 thank you baby got
my baby I added a baby my bad I like
that that's why you hate to work with
the improv no I like being proud that
was good yo way to go in 23 years I just
wanna 23 mar 20
[Applause]
[Music]
you broke the microphone I love you
Leslie I'm sorry Leslie
but that's amazing congratulations thank
you thank you well good well it's for
her it's a it's a big congratulations
for tolerating tolerating me it was
harder for her it was easy for me no
y'all are y'all are like a magical
couple to watch I saw that at Hollywood
gave me y'all are fun subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going